good morning it's your boy guess what
I'm quitting my job which means I'll
probably be back here a lot more but
also I'm gonna be back on twitch
February 28th so I need you guys to go
to twitch.tv slash big boss pose follow
me
turn on your notifications and I'm doing
this big-ass stream we're gonna play
some League Legends I'm a talking bat
[ __ ] we gonna watch videos we gonna hang
out together it's gonna be tight
February 28th okay link in the
description please that's right boys and
girls we're back another episode we're
free ball in it and today we're talking
about tender but it's Cupid corner wait
am I the only person that's actually met
somebody from a dating app I I used it I
used it did you go today well I was
setting up some and and I said now I
went on a date with someone from OkCupid
oh but I think I've said that story a
lot really high okay yeah but yeah it
was only so that I could get that
experience out of the way
cuz I've always been like I only go on
dates of people that I've been friends
with first of mova I was like you know
what I'm gonna open my mind and try a
dating app just because I don't know
what I'm gonna be single again I just
want to get it out of the way to try
that experience I always think damn dude
I don't know how girls survive like
dating random strangers on apps and I'm
just like I would be so scared and
you're the they're the prey in a way
like you don't mean like all the guys
are like like I'm like not pretend but
I'm just out here like saying like [ __ ]
dude I gotta think how do I not look
like a rapist yeah like that's what's on
my mind is like how do I show her like
it's cool like just chill you know
what's so hard is when they don't talk
like how they message you in person
that's what happened to me like this guy
was a writer and so he wrote awesome
like the conversation was like oh you're
kind of funny like I write way better
than I speak to I met up with him and he
did not sound like that oh oh no maybe
his friend was writing everything for
him
I didn't fall in love with anybody I
haven't actually done that before for a
friend of mine he she was talking to
this guy this is when we were in high
school and like I've always been like a
pretty decent conversational it's like I
can always keep a text conversation
going and she would always be like what
do I say to him what do I say - Chris
and I would like tell her what to say
and then eventually she would just hand
me the phone and I was just having these
full-on conversations with him and then
you started like oh it sounds like a
rom-com I didn't like him but then two
days later like he was like oh let's
hang out and she was like you need to be
there I'm like I cannot physically be
there but I won't be cool without you
yeah for me - it's like that Cyrano de
Bergerac movie oh my you're like her sim
character she's like gives me a mask of
her face just marry her for me please
please the whole time she's just
watching the whole thing yes I'm in a
relationship but it's really you say I
do marry him for three months and I'll
kind of just jump in and take your spot
yeah like your best friend on the side
that he falls in love with that has an
affair but actually I was the one that
he should have been with all your good
friend bows dude I I really did talk to
this dude for a hot minute but also it's
fun like it's very flirty like I'm if I
want to play with somebody I'm pretty
good at flirting how did he get you a
good flirter I'm a good flirter I'm
pretty I am how did he make it sound how
did he make you like him how did how did
I make him like me how did you make how
did you start to like him I didn't start
to like him when did you fall in love
with him I don't think she's taking the
bait I think it's happening it happened
to me you know I was in love with this
guy on the internet from the Eminem
message board voice chat a lot and like
so in a bit a bit a year of us and we
were like a online couple on the forums
like we were like a couple and then he's
like can I call you and so he we started
talking on the phone but I'm so nervous
on the phone I don't know how I this
point I really didn't know how to talk
to people on the phone and so I would
have my best friend at the time / - no
no I would tell like like I'd be like oh
my god I found my friend because I just
got nervous so I would just like hand it
to her and she'd be like yo Nikki likes
you so much above up and then I found
out that they started calling each other
separately behind my back message
calling your friend yeah yeah and they
would have long conversations on on
their own they talk about marks whole we
wouldn't call me anymore I was like a
friend stole him from you we stopped
being friends
grah yeah since I've been a citizen of
the internet for like 20 [ __ ] years
everyone that I've ever met I've met
online first so that's why I talk you
mean like cuz you check the profile on
[ __ ] like you met them online I meant
them online well you came from a small
town so it was like you were limited to
social interactions right and then I
went to like a small school and I was I
only went to school for two hours a day
graduated at like 16 so like I was on my
computer all the time that's how I met
people playing video games I met a lot
of people online too but I met a lot of
people in person yeah I know who are
married now from like me like they were
talking like it's some anime forum or
something I don't know and but now
they're married like beat so they they
started they met each other first on the
forums ha my anime and [ __ ] like that
friends yeah but the guy lived in the
East Coast and the girl I knew she lived
over here and then what they would do
after they were talking for like 3 or 4
years at this point but they were
worried about anime so good you talk
about anime yeah and then they would
like video call each other all the time
and stuff and then they started trying
this and best though and you have a
common interest yeah exactly you have a
common interest it's kind of like the
hard part is done because you have a
thing to kind of relate to because the
thing with the the whole tinder stuff
right is like I was realizing that
there's this whole cold layer that you
have to start off because there's no
report the only thing you got off is
like you're like oh they're physically
attractive and maybe you might see a
piece of their personality of what they
kind of want to let you see in their bio
right one thing that I always kept
seeing I thought it was hilarious is
there's this thing where girls would say
oh I'm not here for anything serious
just for like a husband or something but
multiple women wrote that [ __ ] and I'm
like that's so [ __ ] funny
dude I so I was writing a movie about
this [ __ ] right that I ended up selling
but it was I had to get a tinder profile
for it and I'm going through and there's
many girls who are obsessed with
Disneyland
yeah so fully grown
women obsessed with Disney Disney
Princess their first [ __ ] line is
like I love Disneyland and I'm like
swipe every time
sweet [ __ ] office right offer it's quite
long I've done the swipe to like to see
an insight into their mind so I gave you
writing for a movie unless you're
actually trying to date some other
[ __ ] on this act the walls are
closing in no no no research the chick
that I was writing in this movie is
really cool so she would never be that
yes you know what I did because you know
I already had like an online following
and stuff when I was single and like
going to try out OkCupid
I had a fake picture like a different
like a my friend I had my friends
picture up there yeah I had my
personality OkCupid oh okay so I had I
didn't want people to like be like oh
it's Nikki Lee and like accidentally
start messaging like a fan or something
like that so I had my friends profile
picture but I had like my personality in
the bio and then if I like somebody like
if we were like messaging like the one
guy I went on a date with I was like hey
just so you know I like you I do want to
meet up but this is a fake profile like
here's my facebook link and here's my
Instagram link and everything this is
who I am
would you like bait and switch like [ __ ]
no oh that's what I was gonna get to is
what was funny since it wasn't my
picture people I knew like in real life
like people that I knew were messaging
this profile not knowing it was me so it
was like people that I knew in real life
and I got to see their game and it was
bad you with just the way they would
they're opening lines and I felt so bad
cuz I knew these guys in real life there
were comedians or like improv guys and I
knew them and they were really cool guys
like I liked not so you thought so you
thought but the lines they gave this
fake profile that they didn't know what
stuff like like hey it says you live
around me like where your favorite
hangout spots maybe we could meet up
it's like why would you start like that
you live a rednecks talk like maybe
let's talk I'm super aggressive on well
I'm not on dating ops anymore but like
when I was I would be like super I think
it sound like you got ban from dating
app because Bose is openers dick pic no
but my bio I'm not [ __ ] kidding my
bio for the longest time said if you
don't text me back I will show up at
your house at through like in the
morning and tap on your window and ask
if we're still good like if the guy
would look like would look like super
[ __ ] boy I would like message I'm gonna
be like hey Jeremy you're really
attractive but you look clingy and they
would immediately be like what do you
mean I look clingy and I just like I
don't know like are you maybe we should
keep talking like dude I would be I
would damn you push and pull a lot of
people's feelings I'm just I'm just
pretty aggressive in like jokey and like
I don't know if my thing is is that like
I I don't see myself is like like super
like hot or anything I think it's more
my personality so like I just give them
my personality and if you like it you
like it I gave my personality and got no
swipes in the very beginning my bio says
I like smart girls because their head
game is strong dude I thought I thought
you I thought your bio would open with
the sound of kazoo music that's what I
just said oh you trying to steal my
jokes but I swipe on me
I like Disneyland [ __ ] just said I like
Disneyland [ __ ] are their profile
pictures that you automatically go no on
cuz - when I when I mess around with my
friends dinners if it's a group picture
I automatically say no so I'm like I
don't know who the [ __ ] you are
yeah and then the other one is if they
have like the Instagram filter with a
dog nose I'm like what do you try on
your nose you have a nose it's true
people don't trust filters guys do not
trust like if a girl if every single
picture has a filter on I'm like you may
think you look good but people can see
the filter and they just want it's so
common though like like half of the
girls ever I was messing around with it
they all have a dog nose one that's such
a common one that everything is so cute
why do they all do it the basic the dogs
are filter warts at the bottom of your
face so it gives everyone a point of
your chin and it makes your face more
symmetric just think your nose is [ __ ]
up wait what Nelson what's your tinder
bio I've never been on tennis Steve well
my tinder bio would be yeah hi oh you
had one that was like I won't [ __ ] but
I have a girlfriend they don't have a
picture so I might actual dinner bio
it's still out there is me and Nicki
it's a shot of me and Nicki and it says
yo I have a girlfriend if you have a
problem with that you might as well not
even bother still swipe if they're like
I'll be your mistress right by like it's
weird that's a picture me and Meghan oh
there's girls that will do that because
you know what they do if a girl is
looking for threesome she just puts the
unicorn emoji and her bio and just that
one of the chick just loves unicorns no
that means she's trying to [ __ ] you and
your be cool yeah why unicorn though
because a unicorn is a code word for a
girl that does this is the third in a
threesome hmm yeah there's unicorns out
there yeah that's what they call them
dude that's like bronies man Brody's
like a threesome
oh no bronies a guy who likes My Little
Ponies why is that the same like loves
the show loves the ponies like the more
the conventions why they believe in the
moralism of the show I think that you'll
enjoy digging
and figuring out what's going on in that
brain until next time you know what
should happen the the Disney people who
are obsessed with Disney should meet the
man man guys who are obsessed with
Disney because there are a lot of men
who are so this is what they do and then
when they have no but when they have a
kid that kids should be taken from them
in the night and we educated the child
should be taken in the night taken in
the night and we intend to re-education
camp where they were integrated with
society more
[Music]
you